to some degree the entirety of the
system as far as i understand
is written in various variants of lisp
so my favorite program language is still
lisp i don't program it in much anymore
because you know the world has
in majority of its system has moved on
like everybody
respects lists but many of the systems
are not um written in lisp anymore but
psych as far as i understand maybe you
can correct me
there's a bunch of lisp in it
yeah so it's based on lisp code that we
produced most of the programming is
still going on in a dialectic lisp and
then
the for efficiency reasons that gets
automatically translated into things
like java um or c nowadays it's almost
all translated into java because java
has gotten good enough that uh that's
that's really all we need to do so it's
translating to java and then java is
compiled down to uh by code yes okay so
that's sort of that's a that that
um that's a
you know it's a process that probably
has to do with the fact that when psych
was originally written and you build up
a powerful system
like there is some technical depth you
have to deal with as is the case with
most
powerful systems that span years
um have you ever considered
this this would help me understand
because from my perspective so much of
the value of everything you've done
with psych and psychopaths then is the
is the knowledge have you ever
considered just like
throwing away the code base and starting
from scratch not really throwing away
but
sort of moving it to
uh like room throwing away that
technical debt starting with a more
updated programming language
is that throwing away a lot of value or
no like what's your sense how much of
the value is in the silly software
engineering aspect and how much of the
value is in the knowledge
so
development
of
of programs in lisp
proceeds
i think
somewhere between a thousand and fifty
000 times faster
than development in any any of what
you're calling um modern or improved
computer languages well there's other
functional languages like you know
closure and all the there's
but i mean i'm with you i i like lisp i
just wonder how many great programmers
there are there's still like yes so so
it is true when a new inference
programmer comes on board they need to
learn
um some of
lisp and in fact we have a subset of
lisp which we call cleverly sub l
which is really all they need to learn
and so the programming actually goes on
in sub l not in full lisp and so it does
not take programmers very long at all to
learn
sub-l and that's something which can
then be translated efficiently into
java and for some of our programmers who
are doing say user interface work then
they never have to even learn
sub-l they just have to learn apis into
the the basic psych engine so you're not
necessarily feeling the burden of like
it's extremely efficient there's
that's not a problem to solve
okay right the other thing is remember
that we're talking about hiring
programmers
to do inference who are
programmers interested in effectively
automatic theorem proving right and so
those are people already predisposed to
representing things in logic and so on
and lisp really was
the programming law language
based on logic that john mccarthy and
others who developed it basically create
took the the formalisms that alonso
church and other
philosophers other logicians
had come up with and basically said can
we basically make a programming la
language which is effectively logic
and so
since we're talking about reasoning
in about expressions written in this
logical epistemological language and
we're doing operations which are
effectively like theorem proving type
operations and so on there's a natural
impedance match between
lisp and
the the knowledge the way it's
represented so i i guess you could say
it's a perfectly logical language to use
oh
yes okay i'm sorry
i'll even let you uh get away with that
[ __ ] that thing
so
i'll probably use that in the future
without
without credit without credit but no i
think i think the uh the the point is
that the
the language you program in isn't really
that important um it's more that you
have to be able to think in terms of for
instance creating new helpful hl modules
and how they'll work with each other and
looking at things that are taking a long
time and coming up with
new specialized data structures that
will make this efficient so
let me just give you one very simple
example which is when you have a
transitive relation like larger than
this is larger than that which is larger
than that which is larger than that so
the first thing must be larger than the
the last thing whenever you have a
transitive relation
if you're not careful if i ask whether
this thing over here is larger than the
thing over here i'll have to do some
kind of graph walk or theorem proving
that might involve like 5 or 10 or 20 or
30 steps but if you store
redundantly store
the transit of closure the cleaning star
of that transit of relation now you have
this big table
but you can always guarantee that in one
single step you can just look up whether
this is larger than that
and so
we
there are lots of cases where storage is
cheap today and so by having this extra
redundant data structure we can answer
this commonly occurring type of question
very very efficiently
and let me give you one other
analogy analog of that
which is something we call rule macro
predicates which is we'll see this
complicated rule
and we'll notice that
things very much like it syntactically
come up again and again and again so
we'll create a whole brand new relation
or predicate or function
that captures that and takes maybe not
two arguments takes maybe three four
five arguments and so on um and
now we have effectively
converted
some complicated if then rule
that might have to have inference done
on it into some ground atomic formula
which is just a
the name of a relation and a few
arguments and so on and so converting
commonly occurring types or schemas of
rules into
brand new predicates brand new functions
turns out to enormously speed up the
inference process
you